welcome to podcast ville this podcast is
brought to you by blue apron I love it
let me explain something to you blue
apron is the best home delivery service
Lea how good is blue apron delicious
helps you learn how to cook a fresh
nutritious meals yep
for less than $10 per person per meal
blue evil delivers seasonal recipes
along with proportional ingredients to
make delicious home-cooked meal you
customize your recipes each week on your
preferences blue apron has several
delivery options so you can choose
whatever one fits your needs do me a
favor check out this week's menu and I'm
gonna give you $30 off menu menu menu
and I'm gonna give you $30 off your
first meal with free shipping no [ __ ] by
going to blue apron doc carbs last Joey
huh you'll love how it tastes
you'll love how it feels and you'll love
creating them credible home-cooked meals
with your family with blue apron so
don't wait that's blue apron calm slash
Joey blue apron a better way to cook
number two let me explain something to
you people
things are bad all over when you drive
for the road right ride-sharing app
every trip can feel like a walk in the
park with lyft you can pick your own
hours I love it and drive when you want
yeah lyft can make driving the best gig
in the world do you understand me
lyft knows that their drivers will keep
them moving so they do everything they
can to make sure their drivers are happy
on every trip then including its drivers
nobody's any other backers so join the
ride-sharing company that believes in
treating its people better go to live
comm slash Joey today and you can get a
$500
$5.00 new car driver bonus Stan a new
driver bonus that's lyft calm / Joey and
you get a 5 on our new driver bonus
again live.com / Joey limited time only
terms apply get it together I'm at my
lyft driver the other day I got his card
keeping in touch me he writing a book
about lifts I love it yeah
The Adventures of lifts mr. Churchill
what's happened now
Greg Fitzsimmons my favorite Jew
[Applause]
you
of this store and both go to the same
place you and Ralphie people keep that
music going keep that music going me
Ralphie Ricci Cruz one of the girls we'd
all go to the same place the house with
different cars and we always be Ralphie
by 20 minutes and one day we found out
that he would shoot the Gower go through
the drive-thru a jack-in-the-box and get
a couple of boxes of jalapeno popper and
eat them on the way to the [ __ ] house
time when you walked in he'd go what the
[ __ ]
you
here labor of consiguen now the
conceiving is once those drums kick in
that's when the baby crowns all been
leading up to that this is this murky
stuff this is for freedom
you
breakfast Simmons in the [ __ ] house
the Irishman fresh from New York four
months the summer dinner August 2
humidity go home you're washing ahead
but you're still in the greatest city of
the [ __ ] world it's it makes up for
it all that all the [ __ ] people complain
about in New York it's like those are
details the the headline is that my soul
is alive I'm creative I'm write new [ __ ]
I'm bumping up against
Asian girls with open-toed sandals on
the subway looking down pretend I'm
checking my phone but I'm really looking
at those nubby little yellow toes with
the good-good [ __ ] not-self manicures
no paint just the natural color of the
toenail makes you want to go to more
human trafficking joints over on Burbank
Boulevard
hey check the exit 22 whack off on her
toes you say sweetie one of the floor
one on the table put those feet out
listen those [ __ ] world nations over
there you know I always Drive through
either Burbank Boulevard or Magnolia
yeah I go to jujitsu and I hate to take
Magnolia or Burbank Boulevard and I
can't tell you how many times I'll be
somewhere and I'll notice a new massage
ball yep and I'm always this close to
walking in what I go to one what I go
there with my wife it's right over here
they really do a [ __ ] job it's pretty
yeah they got a happy at 29 1 2 3 yeah
oh you take your wrap plus there's a
lone wolf they soak your fear yeah they
wrote from your knees down yeah put your
hips back in place yep they rub your
hands you forms your neck
they twist your [ __ ] neck then they
take you in the other room when they rub
you down and they put hot stones on you
for the small 40 and they give you a cup
of tea on top of tea yeah the [ __ ] that
place is from men and here's the other
tip I got a punch card if you're gonna
go to one of these places get there
before 3 o'clock because they're not
they're not change now the sheets so why
don't you want to be the first on the
dialers sheets
this place is tremendous they may change
the face rest but they're not
yeah rich and how once I've been going
there somebody's kid from jujitsu said
go to this place he's like tell me the
truth and I got a hand job yeah I go
don't make me a little place there
because that place is next for a little
store I go yeah and the two sons always
talk to me about sports and homilies
[ __ ] so that's a massage parlor John a
[ __ ] joint yeah please don't [ __ ]
me cuz I'll be embarrassed if I walk out
and they see ya and one day I was enough
store and I asked a guy if he heard
anything about that I'm thinking of
going over there just to cover myself
legals people love it's [ __ ] busy oh
yeah yeah if I had a sign that said
happy hour 12 to 3 20 bucks neck feet
and legs is on their shoulders you get
it Lee you never know whatever me no I
haven't no you got to buy him a gift
certificate but less he won't go
his girlfriend wolf oh we did deal when
we had yeah I know but you'll do zeal
but I don't know that Chinese people
yeah you only like Chinese people I like
you I like all you don't take you over
there with me thank you
cuz if now he won't go he won't be
allowed to go oh you think I went to a
play my wife gave me a coupon for a yeah
I lived down in Venice and read on
Lincoln Boulevard you know and there's
all kinds of shacks on linkable of all
they do have shacks
oh yeah so she gives me this coupon she
got it in the mail you know one of those
value pack envelopes becomes stuff we
clean your carpets and you go get a
[ __ ]
whopper with cheese and dry cleaning
it's like all those coupons and one of
them is for this Thai massage place so
it's my it's my birthday and she sends
me over there and and I walk in and this
cute little little tiny Thai girl behind
the counter she leads me back to the
room and you know take off your clothes
get under this towel so I'm laying
facedown and I wait you know a few
minutes goes by and then I hear I hear
the door open and uh you ready I'm ready
and then she starts rubbing but it's
like she's [ __ ] strong like this is
not what I expected from this girl and
she's working elbows and knees
[ __ ] you know deep that I was like
wow this is and then and then gets to
the
and starts boiling it up doing some deep
circles like like round so the point
where I'm going like did I take a dump
today where you start worrying about
your hygiene and how it snows and then
she goes get and she gets in that crease
between my ass cheek and the leg you
know she's got her finger in there and I
and then and then there's like a little
ball graze and I think oh then she gets
the other cheek
same thing rubs it oils it gets in that
crease second ball grace now you got my
attention
slaps me on the ass you turn over which
is foreplay for a lot of guys in America
those three words you turn over I turn
over I look up and it's [ __ ] - dude
with lipstick on Asian dude long hair
lipstick gun it's not the woman from the
front desk and he starts rubbing my
thighs in front of my thighs are you
putting of moisture I swear - Christian
and so the dudes rubbing my thighs and
he starts to he starts to go on the
inside and I start to feel a little
pressure and then he didn't go for it
and to this day I think I don't know
what happened like I I can't I can't
look you in the eye and say that no was
on the tip of my tongue at that moment I
think I would have said no it was the
lipstick the lipstick you laying on your
back anybody shows up a lipstick you let
them suck it back you know saying that
you could [ __ ] on the till dawn and show
both lipstick on and flowers and this up
and think this is the way yeah you can
put it you can put a lipstick on a pig
absolutely yes once I seen the lipstick
yeah I'm done that's when I throw the
psych ticket dead
I run the [ __ ] out yeah and then the
cops come and I thought we tried to suck
my dick
yeah but yeah lipstick huh it's not like
contest I'm saying they're gonna check
your dick for lipstick see what a naive
one day I went Jitsu like two days in a
row and I couldn't walk yeah and I got
up that morning I knew exactly what time
it was I went I dropped mercy off I got
breakfast I sent some emails than 11
o'clock I went over there I walk over
there and every time the guys busy but
the best was over there's the girl she's
like a weightlifter yeah
Chinese weightlifter yeah she's strong
and she's very sweet I really like and
the guys are cool too but don't go on
Wednesday she's not up there on
Wednesdays and I went in then I've been
going in and I took my wife there when
she hurt her back now we go together
and it's a great time they got a TV
watch Lolo Chinese people upload all
this for you they love it
black people like Red Lobster Chinese
people love all that is v you go to any
Chinese restaurant thing other than you
are trying to figure out the crime all
they know it already they wrote the
script you don't say these New York cops
they're looking for details they know
exactly who raped her bro
yes [ __ ] Chinese people yeah averages
you go down to Chinatown that that's
what it when they're really stuck they
take that [ __ ] so I go over the other
one day about 2:30 this is like a like I
was high and I was kind of bored they
something go got a [ __ ] massage yeah
looking to do this I had to fly the next
day something and I went over there this
had to be there four months ago and I
went over there there was no parking
even [ __ ] thing there was no parking
of that street yeah and I was like I'm
[ __ ]
so I felt parking like a block away I
walked over sure enough come back in 25
minutes or sit for 25 mile [ __ ] this and
I got I gotta be another one of these
that don't want to [ __ ] suck your
dick
hmm you know I'm saying man
I made it and went down Lankershim and I
made a u-turn I saw like - I went to the
Thai one first and the chick was too
brown for me hmm like she was something
was wrong with her she had got like
somebody left her under the [ __ ] Sun
Tanning boot for three days sunny it was
wrong with this J go to a masseuse
because she's too dark I said the word
wrong she was something was blown okay
so that's good right and Greg didn't
even get up when you saw the juice she
had a be alright I know she had a be
another I said it wrong I'm very sorry
if I insulted but she was like those
people that you put on their a sundown
anything yeah
and they went under for 30 like try it
out and wrinkled like orange yeah I
never saw anybody that skin color you
know and I wanted there and I just
smelled the sperm yeah yeah had a mild
smoke smell of sperm he's black like you
look on the face yeah and I just took a
venue I just said look how they come
back with my I had to commend you okay
thank you would I be open till yeah and
I got the card I split and there was one
two blocks down but I've always wanted
to check out yeah I've been going that
[ __ ] haha for nine [ __ ] years and
that spot there I've heard a thousand
creepy stories but I've also heard that
there's chicks and then I give great
[ __ ] massages yeah I've heard prone
tell them that they try to give no no
I've heard both well it took me three
minutes to know I could smell the error
sperm yeah yeah there were two chubby
dudes sitting there waiting to get
massages and they have like an
embarrassed look on their face yeah like
somebody would go Joey
is that you these guys didn't want me to
know who they were and then they want to
know what the [ __ ] I was too lazy so
you're like a 30-minute wait I said I'll
be back pain and that was it my
curiosity was so yeah if there's a
double door with a lock on it I have
friends you're paying me see this is
like some bulletproof lawyer I have
friends that go those things
something's gotta be like I don't travel
I should have a condom the whole sack
and around the nuts like that the Bob T
is stomach I found something out well
cuz you know how right being a while ago
said the thing about saran wrap
yeah they do that because a condom in
that place is like it it shows what
you're going in there for so they get
charged if you have condoms that's why
they have this Rambler when they charge
you with I don't know probably has to be
like yeah hard for them I don't know
what it does for yeah it's probably
nothing nothing with saran wrap
you're gonna put saran wrap on there's a
problem with your [ __ ] life he was
saying well they're gonna suck your dick
with saran wrap you're gonna stick a
hole with saran wrap something is the
psychologically correct okay I don't
know okay I see them today I wouldn't
got guests just now yeah I got had left
the house of the quarter to and as I was
pumping gas there's one over there by my
Dolph over there that's my favorite gas
station across the Mexican carwash
across the potato talked those Denny's
and the [ __ ] massage parlor that
massage parlors been there since day one
if you look at it you're like they've
killed people
yeah like they've sent the Chinese mob
boss in there and they've stabbed them
in it
yeah it's creepy I've never ever seen a
customer oh is it like on the side of
the street that's great from Scientology
yeah yeah it's been there right for 20
years you've never seen you have to stop
there that's the busiest light in the
valley so you always stop there you look
around at the gas station you look at
the Denny's you look at the potato taco
place you look at the carwash then you
look at the massage ball and go who the
[ __ ] would step in there yeah it's in
between like an engine rotary place and
like a [ __ ] something else I think
it's a lawyer or traveling to something
crazy yes and it just says massage and
years ago years ago before I got hip to
that whole Lankershim Street because
there's a whole thing that was going on
I don't hang out on Lancashire number so
I don't know
when I moved to the valley nine years
ago
Lancashire they were running hookers
there at night and I didn't catch it at
first cracked Lancashire min North
Hollywood right there yeah well I was a
walk there man I didn't catch it at
first and I kept saying it's not
Hollywood
Who am I saying all these cute little
black shirts with hot pants up walking
down Lancashire at 10 o'clock and they
they were come out of that hotel oh they
were working the mother hotel behind the
jujitsu school by the old weed stories
the daughter okay so as soon as you like
this soon as you cross Riverside and you
cross that hand the habit it's on the
right right there that weightlifting
store there's a bodega a weightlifting
store all that there's a hotel behind
that play if you make a right and see
the hotel you're like oh yeah
nobody ever knows it's all the time like
that yeah it's called like the colony
and it's like the colony and I used to
stay I used to stand the fun huh three
nights a week
yeah I'm like an [ __ ] I go look at
this much black chick 11 o'clock at
night
what if she's doing a spot and one day I
finally put it together yeah Wow
so that corner over there when you
stopped at the light you look at it
you're like okay they give massages
playing in gas there and way way way in
the beginning when I first started going
it a girl came out of there one today
like I tell you I would go in there
you mean one of the masseuses came out
of there I have no idea what she was but
if she look like that what her friends
look like and I'm saying birds of a
feather flock together yeah yeah well I
got a place in Venice did I go to it's a
there's a carwash I go to right on right
on Lincoln Boulevard by Washington and
you go in and I don't know how it's so
[ __ ] cheap I mean what does water
cost that they're doing car washes
[ __ ] $9.99 you know with you know
three guys hosing it down and brushing
it you go out there I give the guy $5
tip he looks at me like I just [ __ ]
paid his rent for the month he's like
thank you like it's nothing
for what you just did you stand out the
hot Sun [ __ ] hand polishing my car
for 15 minutes for five weeks I had that
job Jesus so seven bucks an hour plus
tip and figure it out yeah everybody's
your dollars driving a BMW yeah you know
they driving the rocketship they give
you a dollar yeah some do cuz it was a
Cadillac it goes your twenty your dog
busted Cadillac no license plate I don't
work car smells like a [ __ ] dead
stripper cause you're 20 so when they
see that they go crazy yeah so there's a
massage place next door to there so I
dropped the car off and I go I'm gonna
be an hour you know let's just put it
aside when you're done I'll take care of
ya and then I walk right next door into
this massage place and it's like you
said the [ __ ] two hot stones and your
feet and they spray the air with some
kind of [ __ ] eucalyptus spray little
tea when you're done and then I come
back and you always feel like a million
bucks when you just got your car washed
we just got a massage and your car oh
it's the greatest then you got a bag of
weed you don't have to go out that night
and your wife is making your favorite
dish like chicken cordon bleu with
mashed potatoes or something
who's bad with you and I feel lucky you
meddling hey give it a stab in the
middle only if the kid don't ask to
sleep Monday man that's how it's the
only way to start the week this cuz I
just work on the weekends I just gotta
look at Monday as our big day yes don't
feel creepy about massages I'm not gonna
lie
yeah I started getting massages how long
have I been [ __ ] around with you me
maybe six years yes and what else like
two years after once I hurt my back the
place I go to they give me a massage
place they massage first then they put
you to the chiropractor for you're nice
and loose they put [ __ ] buzzers on
you [ __ ]
but the massage is you Studio City yeah
they're not even hurting your feelings
yeah you know I groped me the [ __ ] down
the chick won't shut the [ __ ] up mm-hmm
for the small boy oh she won't shut the
[ __ ] yeah I don't know if it's LA but it
seems like there's a lot more acceptance
for guys doing stuff like that now like
I don't remember a lot of guys getting
massages and and all that stuff when I
was younger but it seems like guys are
you can take care of yourself yeah in LA
it's a minnow New York is the same way I
know a lot of comics in New York do the
jack Shack thing we're all over the
village if you came to me tomorrow and I
don't want to do the podcast no more and
I wanted to be a massage therapist you
know me I giggle five minutes and call
you to [ __ ] masseuse for a month but
after you graduate you know in the
Hitler I'm gonna hold you are great I
won't say age on the radio whatever the
[ __ ] this is podcast but when I was
growing up all those tough guys and
movies always got massages from massage
did it yeah from that big burly yes that
we're breaking their back and then after
go Mel knock it off
you're the saying yeah and they had like
a bottle of vodka next to him so you
could do a shot while he was getting on
the side yeah
so I would go to somebody but between
you and I it's like me go to a doctor I
don't know follow yeah I mean it really
let everything go like doctor wax like
walk in there you know he needs to take
blood I trust everybody everyone every
10 years
yeah the first two years I would faint
yeah well they shot me in the air so I
afraid they had to give me two shots one
on each a sheik
I took the first one half for the first
one I said it's over I left one time
they gave you a physical before the
blood test I left I had to go back there
on but they had to call me a thousand
eligio he take the blood test when I
first started going him I wouldn't even
walk in his office if a needle was
involved yeah
when I went down that go listen this is
what I'm feeling if a needle is involved
let me know right now so I can leave you
we used to be a joke with us like you'd
be like you've postponed like the blood
test I think like 15 times or something
was it even when I started still with
you yeah a couple years ago you were
trying you have to go for a blood test
in like December totaling more do it
aiyoh
diode by the doctor a blood test for
nine months she kept calling me Joey
we're gonna get that blood test I got a
call the other day from the [ __ ] doctor
some guy that wants you to put that bill
look at this box for a month they gave
it to me it's just that what I did my
physical 60 days ago they gave me
another one of those boxes when I turned
15 it gave me a box why is that standard
yeah we should test when you turn 15 ml
your box first they call you they try to
[ __ ] with you yeah I'm saying yeah
you're driving the kids you're thinking
about going to Tampa tomorrow you know
you're gonna take the kids to Burger
King after the soccer game hustling the
phone rings and you know my Kaiser
Permanente you like um he's not there on
the level Kaiser was gonna yeah is this
mr. [ __ ] mr. Kaiser is this [ __ ]
no
Fitzsimmons yes Mr Fitzsimmons Mr
Fitzsimmons first off it wanna wish you
a happy birthday
did you know listen as she's turning 50
your body ages come we need for you to
do us a favor we're gonna send you above
the man I swear to god I'm high as [ __ ]
I'm on the 101 I'm by the my own
business I take the call just because I
took the caucus look the baby was born
at that hospital with that insurance
yeah so I took the call and there was my
wife's insurance but I was under it even
though I had sag insurance I want a good
as true there a lot [ __ ] better
they gave the baby for free yeah love it
Wow they paid for that company the
[ __ ] the baby was free Jack never
done it it's like 15 grand normally it
does admit yeah look at it so he called
me and they said we'll send you a box
we'd like for you to return it with some
feces but I'm like what the [ __ ] is
going on I'm on the 101 in traffic whose
feces I go who's for another I'm already
talking about feces you know
maybe go to the bathroom and take a
little scoop out put in a box and mail
it back to us and self return postage
box I'll take you five minutes at your
time but not the insurance won't cover
you five years from now bunch of [ __ ] I
know listen let me take a bottle or send
me the box
let me take your bag let me look it over
I'll consider wash in the Box I got off
the phone with that guy I'm gonna [ __ ]
in the box he's out of this [ __ ] bird
about a month later I go to my doctor
for a physical another way out he goes
oh by the way huh Suzanne Jimbo's boxes
I'm gonna kids tell me what what are you
talking about is this we're gonna give
you a little box what do you feel scrape
your [ __ ] what in the box
I might deal with this [ __ ] box
though that's why no my wife's insurance
company called me with the same [ __ ]
box story are you [ __ ] in a little box
it's not happening this is a family yeah
it is it's a felony be a foul yeah I
know for a fact if you [ __ ] the box of
mail to somebody who federal mail you're
gonna get a year time let's [ __ ] the
terrorist act piece of my [ __ ] after
four or five days the box have you
opened that with all those nuts in it
and pieces of [ __ ] stems stems and
God knows why yogurt-covered [ __ ]
raisins they that don't digest in his
stomach though chicken wings from the
Comedy Store no I will need nothing from
the contest door I love the Comedy Store
yeah and I love those chefs and stuff
but yeah I think we've eaten one thing
from the table store that was it yeah I
never ate anything from there I'm not
even hungry at that time anymore yeah
I've never been hungry - I think I've
rarely pissed I think I've pissed twice
and all the years there I just when I go
to a club I don't piss and I don't eat
I'm there to work not there to have fun
did you do a lot of spots oh yeah did
you enjoy writing and crashing oh you
mean this summer day I didn't do a ton
of spots to summer I would do like um I
would do I should say you know the Mike
Alohomora trust me sex is love
what oh yeah yeah I spoke to well he's
uh he's got to start playing hockey with
me again we just play hockey together
man your agent our old agent her old
booth so New York was tough because I
would work 1214 hours writing on
crashing and season 2 coming out I don't
know when and and I would be [ __ ]
exhaust 1214 hours sitting in your
director's chair looking at the screen
while the actors are over there and then
these long breaks and they feed you all
day and then after 12 hours I'd have a
spot you know three hours later you know
10:30 at night and I'd be like [ __ ] this
and I'd go out I'd get on the L train
into Manhattan rent the city bike take
it from 14th Street down to the village
park it go inside see Bobby Kelly you
know hang out with some good people but
still but some I got up I wasn't even
that into it I was just like doing it to
do it to make [ __ ] $15 and then back
on the city bike back to the subway back
to Brooklyn you know ten minute walk to
the apartment and I was like I can't do
this so I just started doing a Sunday
night so I was the only night I go out
and do three or four spots on a Sunday
and I go on the road on the weekends I
went out and did a few spots but to feel
it we were mostly working in the village
you know shooting the show not mostly
but a lot of times we'd work at the
Comedy Cellar The Village Underground
shootout there
August middle of the night we're out
there at midnight I'm [ __ ] MacDougal
Street trying to shoot and you know all
the animals that are out there
Jersey tourist from Jersey you know
people from the Middle East and wanna
you know videotape everything there's
something we'll see a camera it's yeah
when you're shooting something it's it
drives you nuts when people when people
see a camera they have to do so would
you do if you want vacation walking with
your child yeah
and they saw cameras shooting you guys
live in Iowa you don't yeah
ya know you'd have to run the [ __ ] over
there and just to see what's going on
those people were okay it was the guys
from Jersey who wanted to make make
noise and and to be homeless people and
this was the racket this one guy and it
happened to us a couple times he can't
he comes up and we're shooting we got we
got 200 extras on the street we got 50
people in the crew union clock is
ticking money's going down the tubes and
all sudden we start shooting and this
guy goes yeah yeah they were like wait
for the tag do it again as soon as we
start shoot well you realize he's
[ __ ] with us
you know he's his homeless guy and he's
standing right across the street he's
waiting there's nothing you can do you
could call a cop but that dudes stand on
MacDougal Street at midnight he can
[ __ ] yell whatever what are you gonna
do and so we go on and that finally the
one of the producers goes I'll take care
of my co give him some money he walks
over every stops and waits he seemed
talking to me hands with some money guy
walks away I go hey me well that was a
that that's just [ __ ] safe just a lot
of money I go how much did you give him
he goes a dollar was another homeless
guy coming up and then you'd have a
[ __ ] then you'd have a fight break
out that always be some some guy from
Jersey with his girlfriend I don't want
to say Italian but you know they're
Italian and they're screaming at each
other and yeah it was it was long nights
we get done at 5:00 in the morning
sometimes that was crazy that's the
thing it sounds fun working in TV but
the reality is like you you got a you
got to work your ass off here's the deal
here's the deal with TV when I first got
here you know I'm a savage you hire me
Greg and I get on the [ __ ] set I
don't go you know I'm not working within
20 minutes how we going Dutch yeah I
didn't understand this whole concept
yeah waiting right I did it
industrial in Seattle for AT&T
will you carry boxes the back
for like their training materials yeah
as they explained whatever the procedure
how to carry a [ __ ] box or something
like that and then I got he and I did uh
I did a pilot for CBS but I had no idea
what I was doing like no idea bill
acting lessons
no nothing my head to the College felt
for a friend
yeah and it was the fester what the
University of Colorado was horrible
yeah he just asked me what was said it's
here keep it dude you gotta get that oh
my god I would pay anything to see that
yeah I gotta get hit in the head with a
bottle or I hit the head in the bottle
did shot the diner but it was funny I
got sponsors and I got like a lady to
donate $5,000 she was starting up a taco
salsa company or something I was just
thinking about that when the guy called
and said do you want to copy that for
your residents right now I said he I
don't know what the [ __ ] going on I
had no [ __ ] idea but then over time
i reaiiy watched other people and the
professionals don't say peep you keep
them there for three [ __ ] days yeah
you know why cuz they keep themselves in
the same mm-hmm they come with
everything CB you you have you have a
trailer
you usually have if it's a great HBO
production or a high-end movie or a
pretty good TV show to have a TV with a
DVR hmm
I could see whatever the [ __ ] that you
can bring your own DVD player yeah a DVD
player
I bring three movies a day yeah Bruce
Lee movies Jones [ __ ] think that's gonna
watch at home yeah [ __ ] that you're not
gonna watch at home in front of your
wife or your kid that you haven't seen
in 20 years then you got some stupid
emotional attachment to if I know I'm
gonna have a 14-hour day on the set and
I'm only gonna shoot two scenes that's
what I'm bringing mm-hmm make up the
tattoo by the time they shoot it the
homeless guy goes uh-uh
[ __ ] watch ten [ __ ] movies yeah a
book a notebook sound you know reefer
myths you come prepared a blow a blanket
a sleep apnea machine went in the
longest shard after a week I figured
that the [ __ ] that I figured it out and
something there making more money than
anything yet these guys are willing to
stand there all day I did those movies
with Dean Cain I learned a lot from Dean
Cain a lot I learned how to act on the
set he was he grew up in it hmm so you
don't Dean Cain a 20-hour day he'll take
that and spit it out he does everything
he knows his lines and I asked him why
he was so good he said cuz of Superman
Superman was 60 dad that lunatic on the
set
who was that chick that was on the show
that I'll write so she turned out to be
a nightmare those are 18-hour [ __ ]
days five days a week can you imagine
that Lee 18 hour days seven in the
morning you coming home at 11:30 five
nights in a [ __ ] row and you have to
have the next day's things memorized
just every you know they have a 12 hour
turnaround but those shows don't give a
[ __ ] ya back there they didn't give a
[ __ ] they paid the 12 hour turnaround
that mm-hmm
that's $1,000 of you're an actor to call
you up the 12 hours bold that's $1,000 I
go in just to sit in the trailer and go
what a waste of money
hmm they just for what they it's called
the force call this is a call before
school yeah for school but Greg you had
to be there they hold that you had to be
there every second it sounded like it
wasn't too bad because we we didn't have
to be there for crew you know crew call
was it like you know an hour hour and a
half before we had to be there and so
we'd show up and it's Judd Apatow so
we're [ __ ] treated like kings it would
be a burrito truck breakfast burrito
truck out front with a whole craft
services table all fresh skillet guy a
guy working the the blender for you
making vegetable drinks whatever and
then and then you go inside you work for
about an hour and a half and then the
muffin man comes around this guy would
have a big basket filled with hot
muffins
those around just when you're hitting
the hitting hump you have another cup of
coffee
and then they would have a pre lunch
meal which was a union thing at like
11:00 11:30 they'd have like a little
pasta station maybe sausage of pepper or
something like that and then you get
done then you'd be off for lunch
you get an hour for lunch and if judge
there you're going to the best
restaurant in New York the whole crew
look now somebody yeah just the writers
been producing yeah whoever and then and
then we come back and there'd be a late
lunch should be an after lunch lunch how
are you not 400 pounds I put this belly
on this summer I used to weigh 150 I
weigh 158 so hi this is fattest I've
ever been and then you get do you know
dinner you end up getting dinner a lot
of times and so you get treated right
and you know it wasn't there was no
drama on set it was like everybody got
along piece of cake but it still put in
hours a lot of time to think too much
time to think you know
so probably weeks was it for you well we
wrote for five weeks in LA in April and
then we went to New York and I think May
beginning of May where there may june
july most august almost four months but
you know hanging out all day with
[ __ ] a tell Artie Lange you know me
and already hung out a lot be a bill I
wrote an episode for Bill burr so he
came in and got to hang out with him and
his wife Nia
who's [ __ ] great and just me and bill
said we'd sit in his trailer for hours
in between takes and just laughs just
[ __ ] crack each other up who else
would come in big Jay oakerson yeah a
lot of guys a lot of funny [ __ ]
and who had a lot of time to kill so
that was the upside crazy yeah it's
great for comedy it's great for coming
yeah it really is
you go to these clubs and
his clubs from the a rooms of the city
to the [ __ ] D rooms packed with John
reader yeah me yeah you know my buddy
Brian [ __ ] runs that Laugh Factory in
Chicago packed on the weekends was
annoying like that
yeah they don't they don't do headliners
handy though though they just get local
guys coming out minute 10-minute sets
through a couple dudes term a couple
spots sell it out so everybody works
everybody's [ __ ] happy as a comic ya
know comedies
knock wood man it's it's doing as good
as it was during the comedy well
probably as big as the comedy boom back
in the 80s right yeah are you still in
love with it
not this year I'm not happy with myself
this year I got a I got I'd finally I'm
finally like getting excited about it
again but for those four months I just
wasn't doing stand him as the longest
I've ever gone and it maybe depressed it
was like I realize it's built into my
system I need as selfish as it is I need
to stand in front of a group of people
and have them give me like positive
reinforcement every [ __ ] night and
from when I'm doing a one night a week
it just wasn't enough
really so now I've been back on the road
the last month and a half and I'm
getting it back I'm getting my mojo back
but I that was the only time in my life
I felt like I was I wasn't sharp I
wasn't you know in control of what I was
trying to do that love you had the first
seven [ __ ] he is things it was
greater than any love you could have for
any woman yeah child maybe left a woman
when you think about you for your third
or fourth earring Carly it's all you
thought about yeah oh you thought about
you know you what you know it's funny
Lee always calls me
did you watch this guy special just came
up
Lyra likes everyone since persons for
thirty [ __ ] years there's twenty this
how many specials can you save a brain
how many specials do you know verbatim
others
anything I know the dice one verbatim I
know
Rodney's water they're probably probably
Steve Martin's first yeah I used to
memorize albums yes okay but now I go
but now one yeah so I guess yeah I could
definitely I could do Steve Martin's
wild and crazy guy I could do Cosby
himself there's uh yeah not too many
after that uh uh
was it something much any are treated
prior yeah delirious yeah I liked Andrew
Dice Clay I liked both broadly young
comedians special along with Lenny
Clarke and it was a mixture it was like
Lenny Seinfeld da Barrera Kennison dice
Hicks Barry Sobel how relief yeah yeah
brilliant
that's the ABCs odd cat no Bobcat was
enough now no Bobcat was on one of them
but he wasn't on that special it was
[ __ ] nuts I rented the one so much
that the video store just told me to
keep it but though he can't be serviced
because there was one tape that I really
enjoyed you're not gonna believe this
it was called Def Jam look stars and the
warm up to a little bit Martin yeah was
Joe Torre Joe Torre came before Martin
Lawrence like Joe Torre would go up
there first through ten twelve minutes
they bring him one more yes won't learn
to do ten or twelve minutes and he would
host Def Jam Joe Torre has a bit there
that is so [ __ ] funny that I'm ever
artist and whenever I see job now paddle
said hello love it
I stand next to him and I do the bed he
just giggle you still remember he's
still doing it no no no no no but he was
I kind of [ __ ] the Europe
Little Joe I watched that tape for a
year and cried like that that's when you
come back I would do like two sets in
Boulder one in Denver one in Boulder and
then I would come home we get a package
of coke and snort coke and write my
goals and I would circle with the club's
I was gonna play at someday someday I'll
be good to play the punchline of Walnut
Creek is I'm like I was just circle
these clubs like Seattle Kai Sturm the
Seattle underground circling certainly
that's back when you got that book they
listed all the clubs at the magazine a
magazine yeah Izzy how many USA or
something it was pull up by John Fox
yeah he was called just the last and it
was a little magazine that came out once
a month I started reading it maybe March
of 1991 it really got me fired on it was
the beginning I had a subscription of
that [ __ ] every month they tell you
they're what headliners were playing
what clubs yes all around every [ __ ]
club in the country told you what the
line of got hard as a young comic you
dick would get hard some damn and a
[ __ ] plant that [ __ ] Club 120
o'clock yeah look Lenny Clarke um take a
little arc job what better let me fly
better let me clog I show and then you
go Bob at the [ __ ] solo the next band
for the 18 people
what a great [ __ ] experience yeah
what a great [ __ ] experience if
somebody came to me with that look in
their eye and said man this is all I
think about dream about I moved into my
car can you [ __ ] lay it on me I'd say
listen to spy mother lay on the fs I
love you want to be a coward
like the first two years three is don't
tell me oh my god Greg it was [ __ ]
rough for years here for fifth year
traveling all around the country doing
trouble runs to [ __ ] the dollar
company comedy whenever on a Nebraska I
was just mixing and matching Yoda I was
going all over a
in car the frame were already broken I
welded it back together
no no that bingo yeah [ __ ] front
bumper fall off
yeah and then one night before a Seattle
comedy competition
it was raining out my tires were bald
and I was doing 90 up a ramp as I was
like number 4 the line up the [ __ ]
new Subaru stopped in front of me and I
just reread them huh and the [ __ ] car
look like a violin it was done I just
pulled it over to the side took my
basketball on he walked over there
[ __ ] see out of family competition I
borrowed the keys from Josh wolf put the
basketball in his car I told them we had
to stop over there
the dude who bought the Subaru just
looked at me he shook his head he was
like even every shirts on this thing
he's like [ __ ] he knew there was no
upside to this experience if you don't
understand the comedic experience yeah
listen listen god bless you
maybe you do a year in your neighborhood
you moved to LA you're young and
good-looking maybe you're just that
funny you come out here and all the
pieces fall and you're the TV and you
got a TV show above our bar you're doing
your graded or 15-minute sets around
town and that's gonna work out for you
for solo until they put you in front of
pressure in Las Vegas and you fold like
a twig because you've never done an hour
right all right they give you a one-hour
special you're not ready when you're not
ready and I chose the other route like
Greg did we chose to muscle it up
yeah hand-to-hand combat whatever let's
do this [ __ ] one night you're in a pizza
place one night you're at the improv
the next day you're in a basement and
there's no water you saying yeah - it's
funny people that aren't in it can't
understand the place like yeah I
understand know this pizza place this is
the good one this is the this is a good
[ __ ] room and they're like you're
playing in a pizza place I'm like hey
you don't get it you know get it wasn't
even the pizza place it was the audience
yeah and the set no that's what I mean
like they didn't there was a liking
order to write the rooms and you know
being rogue and starting out in New
England we would just we would go to we
would drive down to a [ __ ] clam shack
in Narragansett Rhode Island because
they had a [ __ ] brand-new soundstage
and they would get hot chicks and we'd
go down there and you know there was
different rooms in Boston that one was
in a vault it was called the comedy
vault
you know there's a date there it was it
really yeah it's the basement of an old
bank and they literally you walk in and
there's a giant [ __ ] vaults and
you're sitting in a vault that has small
authorities well I'm dick tardies comedy
Lord and and it was a [ __ ] crazy
he was so good that even when I was
getting paid I'd worked there for free
and I would have to stack chairs after
my set and I would still do it that's
how good it was for [ __ ] 30 people
but people understand you're working in
a bet
why you're in a basement now you
understand it's [ __ ] it's like heaven
is though they don't I would love this
and if you can't me but how long do you
think it would last for you guys like it
obviously took long it took I don't know
how long it took to make it but if it if
you guys were now still doing open mics
do you think you'd still be doing it
well 28 years no no there's a problem
that yeah that but now you have to come
to terms it yourself but gonna tell you
something what if what if you've always
been a comedy enthusiast and what if a
Tuesday nights at the red onion they get
65 people and the owner doesn't [ __ ]
open mic that he's been doing since
Jesus left Chicago he's got pictures
everybody who came through there and to
the spot you know he doesn't pay it it's
just a hot club and it's been there
someone's at home yeah so why wouldn't
he do it so you know like I think you're
going if someone did an open-mic fur on
Tuesdays every you every week for a
while I thought that was he stars a
little strong I anticipated this evening
you just got pulled over time you that
mushroom took you for a loop there for a
second I'm trying to save you but I
can't remember either we were talking
about like it when you guys still be
doing comedy if right now you should
were still an open mikes
no but there's a guy somewhere that has
a family that has a job that he makes
Hodgins $50,000 yeah his house is paid
for he's got two cars
he's got three beautiful kids but he
[ __ ] loves coming sure and every
Tuesday night guess what this guy does
he goes down and he battles and I'll
every Tuesday yeah and guess what he he
doesn't have a chance and [ __ ] hell
hmm he wouldn't have a chance you know
if he was they they just doesn't have a
chance that doesn't matter
no psyche being in a garage man you go
stop a guy from [ __ ] thinking of a
basin
Rajyam jam and on a Tuesday age of a
[ __ ] there a hobbyist this complex was
said to me what the [ __ ] Lester no he's
just a hobbyist yeah maybe he's got a
wife and maybe he came to terms that
he's not ever [ __ ] do this he knows
his name the time and the [ __ ] he's got
three kids you know what everything just
comes there was a couple guys in Denver
that would show up and there was one guy
in particular a black guy that sold
insurance he'd show up at this place and
inside was that Boulder but he sold
insurance always coming with a nice suit
he'd do 15 minutes after he drinks he'll
a couple white chick they leave and I
asked him a few times do you wanna go
there on the weekend do 15
that may just be a that's where it is
from yeah and when I went to Deborah I
asked about my study finally there's got
den she's got a lot of comics oh that
are like that that are that have
full-time jobs and a normal life and
they come out and because of that club
is so good and there's other local clubs
they can sleep in their own bed every
night and go out and and and do sets and
not really not really hit the road that
hard that was my plan so I got kicked
out of the economy was yeah in 1994
wendy was starting to like me she was
giving me star spots during the week I
was living in bold that my life was a
[ __ ] disaster
but comi it was time to pick up a little
bit I was starting to get a gig once a
month 200 bucks on the weekend I do four
sets during a week I had a great comedy
a way to develop I was thinking about it
one day Mondays I went to this
Australian bar that was the back of a
back of a back of like what South
Australian place he out backed out back
and this was in the back of the outback
it's at like 18th but they'd have 12
people in every month a the same pro
people yeah I go they eat a bag of dicks
Tuesday but the case to go to the broker
where I got banned from then they let me
back in my go to the comedy works
Wednesday go at club 56 that's why I
threw the microphone at the guy I
[ __ ] hit him in the head with the
microphone well he flicked the [ __ ]
beer thing at me
no but [ __ ] kept flicking beer things
and all the comedian's you're sitting
there watching the comics and you can
see the beer thing bottles flying at the
comics the big caps oh you know
[ __ ] pull the big yeah he was
flicking it they figured out a way to
flick it with their fingers yeah I can
flick in about 25 yes and the comment
and they were going to pass the comic
and they hit one comic and they got to
town like a comedic argument but I want
to tell you listen do me a favor the
first [ __ ] beer cap I see I'm gonna
[ __ ] smack a [ __ ]
I didn't stop saying that but big cat
came at me and I looked at the guy he
charged the table why are people so
stupid
yeah I got a microphone in my hand
listen I belted the whole microphone
broke the batteries came out that was
the best had to [ __ ] D batteries and
I had to stand he went down he was hold
on through his head I had to stand the
other two guys boogie to the back I got
out I made the [ __ ] bartender pay me
the 25 thank God I already had my dinner
is to give you 25 bucks no free dinner
yeah you got the steak and baked potato
and a salad what are you [ __ ] kidding
me half those places out of feed you
that's what people understand people say
why don't you go that buy [ __ ] you ever
have that ham and cheese salad nine
o'clock we haven't eaten all day you
know dude I survived on the Comedy
Cellar for years that Middle Eastern
food upstairs the olive tree cafe
[ __ ] door it's like the best Middle
Eastern food in the city
the hummus is amazing he chooses groups
and then they got a baba ghanoush don't
you said that's a meal in itself he
could just sit there any baba ghanoush
on warm pita bread and be happy no you
could sit there enjoy will even go on
that [ __ ] block baba ghanoush
oh really you only go there yeah it
gives me the [ __ ] [ __ ] but I just
don't like there's like beautifully yeah
so you know just to be honest it is so
what happened you get bounced out of the
Denver Comedy Works my life was
everything look okay I said everything
happens for a reason because I was
already settled like my my I saw what
the Denver comics were doing I hung out
one of the best ones that was dear
friends and I was sitting at his house
and I was watching the game and people
called him and Dennis Miller would be
called him to help him right and you
know all these people he had two other
guys from Denver that one came out here
and had shows they would call this guy
consoling him who brought the ally and
help him right so I knew people
this guy had a gig at the time every
Tuesday he got up and he went I like
AT&T training headquarters and he did 45
minutes as a electrical [ __ ]
coordinator
mhm so he got there with a [ __ ] white
smock
talked about the conductivity of
electricity that he'd belt into 45
minutes of material from their world up
and tricked him to death
yeah he's got a little blue on him to
push the envelope huh
and he'd suck him back in he was great
this guy so any made tremendous money
doing that gig
yeah so he very seldom one on the road
so I saw how these guys were living oh
you know radio was big that there was
three stations and three radio stations
for comedians so they gave you action a
lot of people just started going over
there hanging out and writing pieces of
things on paper and after two years they
gave him a job if you show up two years
at 6:00 in the morning for freely you
get by Jeanette [ __ ] two years six the
morning for free
mm-hmm ever two years ago you're on the
payroll of this one nickel yeah and
we'll give you insurance of a key with a
little ring around your neck see look
important your [ __ ] bum oh yeah and
now you got to do spots until one
o'clock in the morning and then get your
ass up at 5:00 a.m. come into the snow
it's fighting the snow in Denver in the
winter but I said okay if I had my
daughter I have an older daughter
I just don't we don't talk I tried to
reach out again two weeks ago again
nothing so the young one of me having a
great time so when I lived in Denver I
was like I'll be at that you could still
hit Wyoming you could still hit that was
a thousand places these guys wanted to
there was a guy god bless him and though
he's still alive is he's a sweetheart of
a man his name was Bill bow not the
comedian I could call Bill bonnibel I'm
amazed rent so you come on up and get it
I'm gonna give me some gigs tomorrow and
he had kinks all over the [ __ ] place
and he drive you pay for gas
yeah and drive you back and then you'd
go in your car inaudible ways huh I had
a couple guys like that but he was they
would Bilbao he worked on a motorcycle
store and he booked a longest-running
club in Colorado history
it was a with a Denver Broncos training
camp as Greeley Colorado mm-hmm it's
called the Down Under
and it's on Thursday nights two
headlining it's a yardstick the feature
gets a half a yard some Frenchy
yardstick a hundred uh-huh the you know
that's what it was in nineteen [ __ ]
ninety-one yeah me too
it was like my third gate like they paid
me on my third day like 20 bucks to go
up into a guest and then he got me a gig
for the Broncos training facility and do
five minutes I was like my fourth gig
and he booked me on those then he goes
you know just keep calling me and I'll
give you a little stuff they moved me up
to ten minutes like thirty five hours
and then he started feature me and next
thing you know I was co-headline that I
moved to why would I forget what to see
yeah yeah yeah you got this see you guys
had bill Doherty
we had dick target Garvey and his guy
named Billy downs who uh he was uh they
call him no money downs because he never
paid anybody he had these kids he used
to he used to pay I called him Potter
because he was like It's a Wonderful
Life
you remember at the end he's like paying
people have forty cents on the dollar he
would okama so much money he book gigs
all over New England and he had a nice
big house he drove a Mercedes opted a
couple Asian kids you know he went
full-on and then he would uh he would
just tell you he didn't have the money
and it was just so weird because it was
like but I just went to the show and
there was 200 people in a Chinese
restaurant in in New Hampshire or Rhode
Island where'd the money go I I don't
have I don't have a pal I don't have a
pal and so it we just build up or he owe
to every comic in Boston money how much
money do people owe thousands of dollars
I mean I was an opener so he owed me I
think he would me 1200 bucks but I
[ __ ] needed it and so then I go up to
New Hampshire to do a gig and he's there
he would be at the gig sometimes when he
could make it just to check on the
numbers and take the cast the door so I
go up and I
to go on stage I go Billy I said I don't
want to go long I didn't bring my watch
can I borrow your watch so he gave me
his watch
[ __ ] gold watch I do my set I duck
out the other side of the stage and go
out the side door I jump my car drive
two hours back to Boston I get a call
the next morning hey pal build a house
pal you for uh you accidentally forgot
to give me my watch back last night I go
I go that was no accident bill I go the
accident was you not paying me the
twelve hundred bucks
I said let's make a deal and so he goes
okay I can give you I can give you 800 I
go nope
no I already appraise the watch I go the
watch is worth about three grand so I'll
take the whole 1200 in cash in a bag
made me a Dunkin Donuts on Brookline
Avenue at about an hour and a half and
he showed up and he had a smile on his
face he respected me he gave me the bag
he goes he got me pal
he got me and he [ __ ] walked away
with his watch and every other comic
heard about that [ __ ] one guy said he
was gonna steal one of the Chinese kids
you know it was an uproar that it was
the Wild West after that I no money down
I got burnt a couple times for 50s or 25
the biggest burn I had which wasn't even
a burn I didn't have a B that was huh
everything that my rent was 400 by child
support I was 365 between the cocaine
the [ __ ] cheeseburgers like I
couldn't make the beltzman I just
couldn't make the belt yeah I made him
some months um once I broke even so I
worked at national reticle as a car wash
that buddy of mine got me a job but he
was like a tritanus a fitness trainer
god bless his soul so he would give me
the collagen tool and bucks to deliver
flies for him to different parking lots
up front who does that in this day and
age so I got a car from national which
they gave me like a one-day rate and I
had the car for the weekend my friend
said it if I drove down to Phoenix I can
showcase from knuckleheads again
at all four clubs I was like that's
perfect that's how I start my career and
the MCS drove 16 I was slept in the car
all gasp was out of my pocket get there
the guy puts me up showcase walks me to
the office gives me three weeks of work
or something San Jose Minneapolis and
Phoenix that's what they were let they
let me sleep this kind of know that
night and take a shower there and spend
the night in the couch which is [ __ ]
Christian of them at least I'd have to
sleep in my car and when I drove to 16
hours I was on my way you know how it is
great yeah in [ __ ] all right well I
got a call month later the club's the
whole chain will out of business so
really wasn't learned yeah I had fun man
those years especially that one year and
a half and Boulder if I think of my
progression I went to New York for nine
months and that beat me into shape that
beat me into open my shape now what I
was doing in Denver was nothing compared
to the savage bosom that goes under the
open mics in New York City that's just
pure brutality so after I wouldn't saw
how I ran back to Denver the king of the
open mikes because I had seen the other
side I had gone how to bring four people
so I had a lot of people tell him I'll
get your coke just bring bring me the
money for this comedy club and gonna
make him pay at the door that's nobody
got on stage I have all tricks but it
was just I had a great time being an
open mic I love sleeping on couches if I
could do it again I'd [ __ ] do it
again yeah I went down me and my buddy
Tom Cotter you know Tom Cotter
yeah so me and Tom getting a car
together in Boston we're like [ __ ] it we
got it we got a break-in and we had that
we have that well that
magazine were you talking about oh yeah
you know they listed all the clothes
yeah just for last just for last
magazine a week and back then you know
you had to it we would list a club
Booker with an address on it and back
then you would make a videotape and it
was on a [ __ ] you know a half inch
VHS tape and cost money and so we said
we're gonna drive down the East Coast's
and we're gonna get road work we're
gonna become Road comics so we got a map
out we stuck a pet put up on his wall we
put pins in it all going down the East
Coast we're gonna go from we're gonna go
from here down I think we went to North
Carolina and we stopped in every club
down and we did we did guest spots now
we showcased and first but to get a
showcase just to get five minutes for
free you had to first send a tape to
that Booker and then you have to try to
get them and it's back with no [ __ ]
you know no call waiting you call and
you wait and you try to get some Booker
on the on the phone from Charlotte North
Carolina they tell you oh you have to
call them on Monday yeah right then you
figure it right so you have to call them
we're like a hidden phone yeah so the
odds that they received your tape
actually sat down and watched it and are
around to take your [ __ ] phone call
and then have a time that you can drop
in along your route down the coast it
was like we ended up with maybe three
three or four spots down the whole
eastern seaboard but we got him and we
got in the car and we just drove and we
stopped and we stopped in different
places and it was [ __ ] it was like
the greatest trip of my life
drew wood was so making no money I know
it was the comedy zone in in North I
think was North Carolina no no we stayed
on the covers over the Charlotte yeah I
think with Charlotte liner and we were
in Virginia at Richmond Virginia was
definitely swash and DC was a stop and
it was like we felt like stars we felt
like look at us we're in a car driving
to a gig we're making no money we're
getting five minutes the biggest [ __ ]
thrill we had
lined up fold-out couch is the whole way
friends I remember I got my dick sucked
in DC by a girl from Boston University
that I knew who put us up I tried to
throw a move on her her roommate who was
sleeping on the other side of us she she
sucked my dick and then I hit on her
roommate who was sleeping in the bed
with us and then she got pissed off me
and threw me out in the morning like I
couldn't have been just happy get my
kicks and a free room and and I remember
I got two weeks I got two weeks out of
work out of it I got a week in
Jacksonville Florida and a week in the
Bahamas and they were paying me $400 for
the wheel oof yeah right right you got
of they were they were running Charlotte
yeah and and that was it I was off and
running you know that was my first and a
lot of the guys from Boston ever worked
the road because it was so much work in
New England you just stay there and you
work like I said Maine one night New
Hampshire Rhode Island and they pay you
cash you make a hundred bucks a night
maybe you've spent 20 on gas because
you're driving a [ __ ] northern New
Hampshire never a hotel room and then
and then I just decided I want to hit
the road I want to go work around the
rest of the country and see if I can
make it work and it was a pay cut it was
way less money to work the road but I
knew that that was the play down the
road was to become a headliner by you
know going on the road man
I do I had I got to LA him I knew I had
holes in my game listen you know what
I'm not gonna sit here and try to work
on an LA and I just went to the dingy
cities for a year hmm six shows you know
a weekend stay in a condo for 50 condos
reeking of sperm like a Chinese massage
I was [ __ ] dirty curtains dirty tub to
sporks is no silver just to sporks but
you sit here but then again you go to
Michigan then they put you in a court
whatever where they have free breakfast
in the morgue yeah quote you're married
I probably you know like one day I got
the Michigan a day early with no dough a
box of change a box of changing sinks
and then six ounce veggies from Subway
I landed [ __ ] in Detroit I get to the
giggling what are you talking about here
daily I'm like okay thank you
is there like tomorrow at 3:00 you could
check into the courtyard bury it so I
went over to the koi yeah be like I'm
booked I am I just slept outside the
Boyard bag was it the winter no I was
like I'm a moral Day weekend 1995 yeah
and I [ __ ] this is a crazy as we get
like I drove to Michigan from Boulder
Colorado in a car that was a soldier
hmm like if I could find this car today
I would buy it out of respect
yeah what I put that car there was a
Datsun be to tell ya four-door white
with blue interior the air condition I
keep meeting it I never got another car
that was that call to have I'm a bit of
the summertime having that turned the
[ __ ] of airconditioning now yeah the
air conditioning was old-school Japanese
like they they invented this is Suki
mocking where they got hit with a bomb
but they can't feel [ __ ] it was [ __ ]
crazy
yeah this air lasted no no that car was
a different car
but this air lasted this call was at
last of me two years of let's just say
Boulder to Detroit and Baltimore was the
two cities that game he worked in the
beginning and I get that little [ __ ]
call filling up the back had a little
section just for the metal thing for the
radiator mm-hmm duct tape for this a
spare tire the blow tires just in case
you have performed with it yeah I had
everything in there I was like a little
Puerto Rican mechanic I could fix it
yeah when I went to Detroit I went that
night early they tell me bad news and
then I go I go where do we check in
someone gonna quote you huh Mary about
three blocks away and make a left and
the one over there was no security
guards there was no security guard I go
into the property and there was like a
tree and I wanted to know the tree it
was about 5:30 the wind was blowing the
Sun was I'll never forget this I was
sitting in the car go I put the seat
back hello and that musical and the call
was 3/4 full but I had a box or change I
must have had 30 bucks there a change I
had like four joints but this does our
bad life was I like a half a sandwich I
know this is it just of it I had a
blanky of pillow and also my pager goes
off [ __ ] and look at it and it's
the clock and I [ __ ] gonna pay for my
calmer they go where are you when I go
oh is they gonna get the hotel no don't
don't though we're gonna put you in one
you have a suit like oh yes I'm gonna
put on the suit you guys suit I had
everything to that car no [ __ ] I have a
shoot in the back hanging really okay
what I did was a yeah man I took a
[ __ ] tool when I put in the back oh
yeah I've seen that road warrior Trek
well I left the second oh I left the
section open for my head yeah just in
case I had to sleep there uh-huh I could
breathe it night you follow me
like a happy together everyone so why
you can't sleep like a Szabo every night
yeah you could just sleep like this for
a [ __ ] two nights and one of those
flood seats and you lose it
yeah and I would sleep in that way two
three nights in a row I would sleep in
my car lay under a tree kind of parking
one of those things with truckers oh
yeah so I put my Sunnah I checked into
the hotel to shower
they had towels I had never stayed in a
hotel there towels like all those like
good night yeah and I [ __ ] went to a
club they gave me spaghetti him whatever
you want order from the menu were taught
us and then they said wait tony bennett
comes here when he does the theater
after the theater he comes here for
dinner every year it's a tradition he's
going to come and play the piano and do
seven minutes in front of me keep it
clean I didn't know nothing clean
I had nothing back there writing jokes I
like art [ __ ] jokes about spaghetti
unbelievable it's what you do it's you
to do the seven minutes yeah how'd it go
what do you think as far as people say
no we're them last thanks Tony Bennett
came to that Club no that's why I play
I'm nobody play this song for eight
years don't never come on the podcast
after the bombing I did in front of him
he gave me a hug you gave me like a
five-year lease really the other way
please
you're embarrassing me just I'll pick up
the tab don't worry about that he's
pointed me pointed the way that is
terrible
- coochy Bobby I don't want that energy
in the club yeah believe that [ __ ]
dark mr. gods of Godzilla
I saw a car in the parking lot I'm
pretty sure it says it's got a box to
change and a [ __ ] day
like all that was just I had everything
in there a pillow a blanket basketball
basketball shorts goggles you know if
it's if anything to pack the books hmm
you know flashlights batteries anything
if it was the end of the world though
hmm
I had a few days do your porn in there
don't know porno magazines nothing ahead
canned food I had sternos you never know
little chug chicha hmm the little
[ __ ] I would buy 10 of those things
when I hit the jackpot like a 20
I'd buy those Vienna sausages huh I just
put them in the back when you taste some
4:00 in the morning when you get up in
the car and you're hungry you got some
saltine crackers something in a sauce in
the trunk you had sausages sitting in
the backyard or uncooked pork sausages
would I hide them back there I'd keep
them nice and Jesus so I can wander or I
can save doremi
you know a feature acts are done you
don't make no money yeah oh it's
primitive style and you know I sit back
now goofing around and everything and I
don't really make me a better comic in a
lot of ways yes it did it'll earn me how
to call audibles
and they're really healthy yes because
it made me build character and you can't
take that time away from nobody no
matter what it was I knew I did it the
right way yeah four years I did over
three million sets a year I used to
count him write the material I did how I
did if I bombed how much I made I was a
fine woman I still have those notebooks
I still I have notebooks with the you
know the pockets the pocket divider
notebooks
stuffed with every set list of every
[ __ ] show I did every night I make a
new set list even it was one joke
different than the night before I'd have
bullet points and I'd save them and I
put the date on them and I have cassette
tapes boxes of cassette tapes I [ __ ]
saved every five minutes set that I
bombed for years I had all that [ __ ]
and the spreadsheets with how much money
I made how many miles I drove what I
could write off because at the end of
the year I wasn't gonna pay any taxes I
called my accountant said you send me
every dime you spend on comedy and I
would send him like envelopes stuffed
with receipts spreadsheets that I
handmade spreadsheets but I went off the
radar from 1991 to like 2003 nobody knew
who I was not that I had a pager don't
bank account no nothing if you had us in
the [ __ ] state trooper if I'm a dog
just pay paid in cash
yeah when I decided to do calmly I was
at the end of my [ __ ] wit yeah that
was at the end I just went through a
[ __ ] divorce and this was it this was
it this was it there was no I gotta look
who's got a restaurant in Boston there
was nothing this was it I had done it
all I had burned every Bridge and this
seemed like the logical I don't like
working days and it's nights and you
drive and you travel when you sleep in
hotels I like all those I loved all
those things so I signed up for those
trouble runs I would do six weeks there
were all those children's hmm and I come
back to the comedy store a [ __ ]
gorilla yeah you do six weeks of you
know cuz half the weeks of morbid and
you don't know what to get that when you
get the schedule says be careful with
language it's a morbid rule ha now
you're [ __ ] tell me on a Tuesday night
you tell me
so it really teaches you how to be a
comic yeah and I would always book
comedy clubs in between I guess that you
know I'm saying so if I if the night
ends of that story or Oregon I call
Harvey's and trying to a guess that and
then the week they're a Sunday night do
five minutes just to see rate how I was
doing
mm-hmm so it's I love it I wish I could
go on a triple run now for three weeks
and tape it
with two dudes at this age I'd see how
crazy it was back left its Roadhouse's
right yeah but it's that he has like
Thursday Friday Saturday we have to
drive all the way to Idaho mm-hmm or fly
to Idaho get a rental car that's the way
to do it you drive
you fly to look at the biggest location
and we end up you look at where the
airport is and you fly home from there
oh because if not you go crazy yeah
there's no reason for us to drive two
days to get up there might as well pay
the [ __ ] plane ticket and you got a
[ __ ] rental card and my three miles
away from the airport you save a bunch
of money right there mm-hmm yeah that
was a thing in in New England it was
never a hotel there was never no there's
no hotels no understand so yeah some
nights you have to drink sleep in your
[ __ ] clothes mm-hmm before you try to
hook up with a waitress there's always a
friendly waitress and you get the word
from the other comics look for Angie
Angie's got a pull-out couch it's gotta
just go through your all but he goes to
sleep around 9:30
you're good you're gonna have to get up
early and get out but that's a place to
sleep I slept it so many people so many
people's homes like that description hmm
that you'd be stand there like a Mook
and then go you driving back plate but
wait I was thinking about you know get
my boyfriend a little mile for me I love
for you to sleep on the couch and you're
like this this chick wanna [ __ ] me
boyfriend I walk in with me
and next thing you know you go over
there he's cool as [ __ ] yeah he sparks
you up she changes you had two titties
hanging her father but they leave your
we Ephesians yes yeah yeah that
[ __ ] never gets feature acts a
[ __ ] hotel yeah we got a spare room
back there make yourself comfortable
yeah
like oh my god they're gonna come in
here [ __ ] me in the morning and you wake
up in the morning you smell bacon
yep you know and they cook for you doing
what the [ __ ] my dessert is and they're
like we have to go to work but you could
spend the day is a remote control they
use our shower do laundry be our guest
in you're like I just met you
yeah last night I could be a mass
murderer and you're leaving me in your
home and you [ __ ] something happens
to it like you're like for a while that
happened to me all the time people I had
no idea I've been doing a gig in
Baltimore for Roger Paul one time and it
paid a little extra which I thought was
odd and when I got there the people like
no there's no hotel that's the hotel for
48 miles from here did you know this one
when you came here and go you're coming
right
they don't notice an ordinance here and
it's like a chemical something you gotta
drive 48 hours 40 [ __ ] eight I had no
idea you know what that's like at
midnight when the show is over
yeah for somebody to drop there was no
rulebook why would you still do the show
if they can't have hotels there it's
[ __ ] because the roger paul told me
there'd be a hotel there that they were
gonna take cami but when he told me the
number chemical plant that's a little
high for roger paul deal saying yeah i
knew there was a by the way when i get
there i hadn´t meet another comic like a
baltimore we had a drive like an hour it
was one of those [ __ ] gates
he was Baltimore on paper till you got
there and they throw by the way you know
it's an a little boys whatever the
Baltimore then it's an hour west of
Baltimore I think they killed 18 people
in that town or something like that and
that's the details of the way you got to
get down a one-way
yeah you see cause abandoned [ __ ]
candles everywhere you like what the
[ __ ] happens flowers of the flowers yeah
not animals you have no idea people at
home you know you have no idea no you
think you have an idea but I don't my
first row gig how did this share a room
with a man listen the last time I said a
room with a man was a present that
wasn't the mobilising thing that could
ever happen to you as a human being
things that your brother or your best
friend I get it but just the shield I
wanted a triple run with time we get to
the whole time they're like man we just
had a fire
we're like what I said we just have fire
we only got one room available for you
guys gotta share room I just met you
yeah I just met you you know how
disheartening that was I was leaving
bold to pursue my dream and I get to the
hotel at my hotel lit on fire the week
before so I got share room with this
[ __ ] schmuck that's that's how my
life openly mmm
so a lot of people after that we just go
[ __ ] that and that shared a room and I
shared the room oh we had Chinese food
together we thought stories that said we
went to bed we turned left a lot I slept
my clothes on our life
mr. K stylist had the [ __ ] suckin eggs
yeah I did a gig in Green Bay Wisconsin
one time the Green Bay funnybone had a
beef 15 years ago more 20 years ago
yeah 20 years closed he was booked by
the same guy that booked the funny bone
and in the end yeah she's not still
openly funny bone Indiana at town is
called Mitchell wocka
it surrounds Notre Dame or one of those
college yeah nobody knows about it that
funny bone but that one that one at
Green Bay man it was it was the worst
[ __ ] gig because it was like a
warehouse we almost I almost feel like
it had a tin roof and and there was no
windows and they all changed mo you know
there's people in Green Bay
they all wear Green Bay Packers though
the women wear [ __ ] Green Bay Packers
jerseys in general we sort of realized
it was time to overweight and their and
their drinking you know when they bring
out the buckets a beer instead of just a
beers right and in everyone's
chain-smoking
and their [ __ ] terrible and then you
leave and they bring me back and I'm
staining again I'm the feature act so
I'm making 400 bucks I don't know how
the [ __ ] I gotta drive out there I did a
tour I did Chicago and that I did that
and I get to the condo and there's
there's a the MC the feature act and the
headliner are all staying at the condo
and I get in there and I'm the feature
so the headliner he's got a bedroom with
its own TV and it's got a bathroom no no
TV it's got a big got his own bathroom
and then the the feature act that's me I
got a I got a room with a shared
bathroom in the hallway that I'm sharing
with the MC the MC is sleeping in the in
the living room on a fold-out Ottoman
not even a fold-out couch you know the
thing you put your [ __ ] feet on the
ottoman you take the top off of that and
you unfold it and a single bed pops out
sounds come to that [ __ ] had to
sleep on a full that out um and not only
that the headliner was smoking cigars
and he wouldn't go to bed until [ __ ]
3:00 in the morning and he has feet up
on this poor bastard's bed he's got his
few and it was like a six night gig it
was like Tuesday to Sunday it was the
middle of the winter it was blasting
cold and there was nothing you could
walk to oh I picked that gig one time
and I got a taste
I got good coke for the gig didn't
bother me
Haley did if somebody in the kitchen had
[ __ ] his foot like I got the Green Bay
and I think I was there two minutes and
somebody asked me we heard they got some
point in the back calling the back bring
40 hours and I remember bringing 40
hours and the first night was like
Tuesday when isolate that Wednesday
there was a two-man condo and it wasn't
bad yeah the guy who booked me there was
from the Misha why is it still open
no it's closed yeah - Mitchell walk a
funny bones it was the same guy I heard
recently died he wasn't a bad guy the
room was dead they could never make it
work I'm a man having a conversation and
in the end I'm going somebody big was
there that weekend when I was in Indiana
guest doing a guest spot and he goes we
got 60 people from Asia it's just a lot
of comedy you know they love football
they can't get them out of their [ __ ]
mind
yeah he does it just does not work and
there still to this day no cop no comedy
and green but hmm they gave up they gave
up they tried again for a while Green
Bay Miami Beach South Beach New Orleans
New Orleans never had every time they
try to room not a will because don't
want is a [ __ ] they drink and think I'm
gonna get hammered and Bill Cosby's
cousin to show up and put a bill in
their [ __ ] pina colada
that they drive through they think it's
cool and walk around with pickpockets
and people with chlamydia
this is people a filthy dog that's the
first place that's that I've only been
skinned in two places in my whole life
San Francisco and New Orleans that was
shot the [ __ ] De Niro movie the time
I went to the door one night I picked up
a one-nighter with time I was I was
staying in Houston and some Booker
called leaders listen man this whole
town needs three comics 25 minutes 400
bucks apiece on the hotel the hotel I
was like you know what four bills it was
a coincidence always what's the drive
six hours I'd do a standing up ahead a
rental cars shot down New Orleans
being the [ __ ] headline I think I was
had when I wasn't looking and next thing
you know they [ __ ] I get there I do
the gate and that and the gig was
horrific
I never bombed so hard in my life at
anyone it was like I can't believe my
bumps are I got cocaine within three
minutes I just stood then somebody came
up to me thought that they actually is
in Jena I felt that it was a [ __ ]
Boulder I didn't talk to nobody you just
talked about bunny target about there
was no pictures those days there's no
hugs
there was no CDs and you needed to see
me leave Orson and if you ask over
everybody I only get something out of a
comment directly from the stage to your
room peel yeah I locked myself in that
but that couch against the door so
sweaty can't get it
that's who that Vegas you [ __ ] up said
he's gonna put the conjugates and
thought I shouted that [ __ ] thing oh
my god [ __ ] yeah I would go up there and
I was rotting to death one that I was
whacking off I was sweat to death three
bang good coke let's go [ __ ] easy
that's crazy where else I lost my mind
at the Cleveland at The Improv I went
there twice before and it was calm and
then the third time I went after a
longer shot I just sleep for two days
I didn't sleep [ __ ] Saturday and
Sunday and we got on that plane Monday
morning Jack the tilling Diesel's
oh my god that's terrible isn't it yeah
Lisa L how you doing boy friend
I'm pretty uh pretty good let me give
some shoutouts is [ __ ] gonna talk to
Greg about a few things I'll get the
[ __ ] out it's a beautiful podcast will
loose
Tice what's up Greg you both good to see
you good hang I need it was beautiful
Johnny crews mind the breeze Paul
Cunningham Billy Barron JT bars liquor
Mike men Damiri whatever very day Robbie
I'm sorry Mike yeah riggan babies dove
Reptar and overdragon that's a bad
[ __ ] right thing I'm saying
where you at this weekend Tarzan let's
see yeah next weekend I'm gonna be at
the where am I going
doctor grins Grand Rapids [ __ ] with
the Christians yeah some of them I love
with you that's at home with a Christian
red claw bear good [ __ ] bed you yeah
yeah that'll be done where you go then
I'm gonna be in a Spokane Spokane or
Spokane wash your the call it I'm gonna
be there at November to the fourth and
then I'm gonna be coming out to after
that to Atlanta the punchline November
18 through 20 and then after that
Nashville and after that Tempe so good a
fit stalk on four tickets were you for
New Year's uh home with the family baby
you do use sometimes I do but it's got
to be a place I want to be I got a
couple offers that were places that I
just I pictured a lot of sadness you
know
it's got to be a place where I know some
people or alright I feel like there's
gonna be a things to do ya know the
fence well I'm thinking about doing to
be honest II it is um important with
that Wednesday and Thursday before New
Year's hmm right after Christmas what
day they what day of the week is it is
who uses a cell that's three years in a
row it's been on a Saturday double check
it but those double check it do you ever
counted in your phone everybody got a
[ __ ] yeah I did Portland for New
Year's one year would you say it's
[ __ ] great it's a lower point who's
always grace great problem has become
this [ __ ] will it's a Sunday New
Year's Eve is a Sunday ooh yeah whoo so
that means you would do Wednesday
Thursday and I'd have to stick around
[ __ ] no oh I'm doing you don't do it
look Wednesday Thursday I come back
Friday more than 29th I come back I
spend the night at the house in LA I
relax with the baby
and sadly want to be the wife again in
the car waiting we gonna Ventura or this
way down the other one Huntington Beach
or in those places got a hotel room with
the family for three days nice well then
we work like savages three days one hour
from my house you've seen on New Year's
Day do that Louie a day before New
Year's Eve and New Year's Day you head
home about two o'clock we did that we
drove to Utah yeah years ago we drove to
Utah State in a [ __ ] small town bad a
little little ski hill bunny hill
nothing but the kids were learning how
to ski we went there and we just spent
three days relaxed away from all the
chaos watching High School Musical at
night going to bed watching High School
Musical every night they played they
played one two and three three nights in
a row we were there every night watching
it it's [ __ ] great
if you had a good time but this year I'm
home this year we're gonna do you know
go down to Venice Beach they let off the
fireworks throw a move on the old lady
you got to do that dirty little remo sad
on me I will else maybe I'll maybe I'll
take some of those mushrooms yeah yeah
give the wife a little space got a couch
with someone right right maybe crows
annexed all set the mushrooms to come be
a dick down so your heart don't beat
them I'm right for the [ __ ] thing you
deal with joy whatever people don't be
violent in their heart start to me slow
down look Jim so yeah I took the viagra
one time I almost passed and all the
blood left my head years ago I was
talking to this freaky chick I could go
walking and she was telling me listen
hello bud eat my [ __ ] but hold on let
me take those Alex's cuz if I eat to Z
this is our [ __ ] blow this room up
put my [ __ ] [ __ ] juices I said you
know what you take two sentences I roll
enjoy and I'll get back to it I said a
direct quote yeah oh my god she's crazy
she's a little white dirty girl with a
lot of hairy little monkey from the
seventies you know one of those monkey
from the 70s it's got a lot of hair
growing on the sides of the leg God look
at the twice like what do I do
you don't say but you got three lines
you don't give a [ __ ] you look sad you
hope it's not a dick in there somewhere
but you gotta take a chance anyway there
ain't no cameras there ain't no [ __ ]
you know cell phones two people are
gonna leave this room I took a peek but
those little back there somewhere
[Laughter]
but you're all joint I'll beat you back
yeah to bestow everybody gives Alex come
on
oh yeah blow [ __ ] did I blow dried your
face you saying where they go so well
those things yeah and then I heard that
once again somebody said that did they
buy zanuck so their wife seats it so
their [ __ ] comes I was like well maybe
the same will happen for me I can relax
so it was so any other palpable douche
may be a star death may be a mushroom do
like a little Belushi cocktail yeah and
go your bum but I will watch the hard
dick give same give her a lot of that
mushroom sperm in her mouth she'll wake
up feeling all dizzy and [ __ ] like that
[ __ ] bat sperm I shot your boat you
will go take some outfits Elsa [ __ ]
filthy animal she's gonna peel her
tongue out the river mouth the next
morning oh yeah you gotta shoot at me I
don't give a [ __ ] right down there
though you know I don't move I try
always next thing you know they got
[ __ ] half of my nutsack
you know I'm saying going down this road
looking at me always why did you tell me
yeah sure whatever I said your telegrams
to Lucille what the [ __ ] yeah you
talking something dirtier than they they
bounce over you know I really want to
come on your face but I couldn't get to
it look it has this bit that wiping
their tongue with toilet paper those are
the best thing they go home the rest of
the night they talk to you I like a
twitch you [ __ ] their world up by
shooting a [ __ ] one of those three
day loves you have a white kid that you
steroids you smoke - verb is deadly
understand you take a couple shots of
that and see what comes out you ask
those football players and you can bring
it back to life let me ask you son did
you have some weed Google coming out of
your big as drove me out for three weeks
yeah you never say you didn't you get a
jerk-off more my wife said this me one
night you get a jerk-off more it came
out oh yeah you know I saved that [ __ ] I
bet Pilate it's my wife that's why
liggett's I set her up sometimes I
better watch a movie or be I don't
really want to watch I trick around the
beginning give me a little mix up real
quick before the movie starts I jerked
off in Cleveland today of my new book um
and I'm sitting at the desk and I start
I start I look up I don't know what I
was thinking but I googled eatin ass
lesbians eating ass and I start watching
it and and you know middle of day I get
the curtains open as a [ __ ] office
building across the street
I don't give a [ __ ] I got my pants
around my ankles I'm sitting at the desk
got my naked ass on that plastic chair
and I'm and I'm spanking it - two girls
eating each other's [ __ ] and so and
so I think and I and I stopped halfway
through and I wattle over to the
bathroom and I get a hand towel and I
bring it back to the desk and I throw it
on the ground in front of my feet and
then I jerk off and all sudden it come
like a banshee I haven't jerked off in
days I come like a banshee [ __ ] good
and so I go to pick up a towel and I
left and I came all over my sweater II
gone it drilled straight down the only
sweatpants I had to wear for the whole
[ __ ] trip
the ones I fly home when it's so
I said I got another hot towel I'm
wiping wait for the spooge off my sweats
I got a hairdryer after that she won't
come on I thought it was out and then I
said put my pants long shirt saw the
waist I thought I was a monster I
thought that sperm must have gone six
inches easy straight down well that why
qualified home I do my office and I just
cover my robe yes I do and I leave tell
it over the [ __ ] app I walk around
with like three shots unloaded my little
rope what is it about being a dad that
makes you get a robe when you're
disgusting in it because it's right
there it's right there the road you can
[ __ ] your Road see you wipe it on
different parts of the robe each day no
I'm Malou here with the roam off
together the different combination these
animals get a cup and jerk off into a
cup I jerk off into a road you do it you
filthy animal your wife gave you one I
used the rope for a fact you know saying
oh you jerk off into the road
that's what now when I'm in a hotel room
on the road not that way AUSA's family
Isis family
I just jerk off on the floor everything
that made comes any three days later he
told hardwood floor guy like 19 stays I
walk over and everything it's like a
forensic [ __ ] when I'm gonna tell a
disgusting Pig
I'll jerk off in the tub and I'll
[ __ ] put the cat down I'll let it
grow for two days I'll put the no
Disturb sign by the time the maid goes
in there got sea monkeys I've been there
feed them toenails [ __ ] let's say I'm at
the computer right let's say I'm at the
computer I got my notebook here my whole
set is right here I got four plugs here
I got a light I got the menu from the
Chinese restaurant
I got rolling papers in this desk and
then there's sweater oh my god I got
everything right I got a maid
pen workin I got my nicotine dump and
I'm watching TV right there and all
sudden something the thought comes to
mer close right there in the office that
little section like the doors right over
there and the beds right behind and
there's a mirror right here and this is
a [ __ ] window here but the air is
blown to you back so you're [ __ ]
you're frustrated cuz you gotta put up
with it sweatshirt other than your old
[ __ ] office yeah I'm saying
it's not even your office it's your
hotel room but it's your own bucket
office right there
take that [ __ ] Cuban egg roll out ah
I just sit there my legs open it's
always like a wooden thing as I can get
garbage can that first off after 40 for
the trajectory leaves a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ]
juice comes out it's tremendous you
catch a young girl off card you might
choke on a debt it's like a gal than a
half comes out they don't even know what
to stop
they just keep looking at you like well
this is gonna end like oh well you can
hate 44 and you don't get laid every
[ __ ] day and thought you swells up
every time you go to generation came up
for air like a swim yeah yeah you shoot
like my trajectory is gone those days
like I hit the wall those days are done
but if I'm in a hotel room and I was a
comedy club hotel room even if I pay for
it sometimes I'm sitting there sometimes
I said my old turtle naked I pick a
little towel and put it over the seat
and I just said my hotel room if you're
watching Lord oh that's afraid the more
yeah I just said they're relaxing like a
doctor and I won't boil it I go what the
[ __ ] I'm naked let me beg what I just
beg we're not right there wherever it
falls it stays and I'm saying yeah I
just walk around I come in like Sally
the lights hitting it
if the lights hit me you can see little
circles on the floor that have some get
you the veil carpeting yeah no no way
sometimes if it's carping I'm in no
danger I mean that could've got there
anyway I don't care what the DNA does he
is saying walking on there giving
Oh Jo I'm bringing sandals every time I
go on the hotel I'm an animal oh yeah
I'm an animal you got to assume but you
got a hotel the guy that stayed there
and funny is an animal first thing I do
is wipe down the head [ __ ] bored you
think maids wipe down the headboard oh
yeah next thing you know you got him a
loop with his my Luke did you scratch
him like a [ __ ] Banshee yeah and then
you go on the airport to the plane
before I sit down wipe that headrest God
knows who will Johnny arrest the firings
in there he hasn't washed his hair in
two he is cause he loves Bob Bob listen
I don't give a [ __ ] okay you gotta watch
that [ __ ] mop on your [ __ ] head
put some water on it come on put a bag
over when you fly you're scaring people
increase your feed you know and and what
I do is I get to the hotel room and I
turn that thermostat up about two more
degrees and I take all the covers off
that bed because those covers are not
getting washed she'd only I hide those
things really if they give you two beds
I rip the blanket off the other one and
they put the head down the [ __ ]
penguin yeah and it's never cold enough
yeah it's never cold enough I got to
bring a fan on the [ __ ] Road from
though yeah so when you jerk off on the
road do you do you watch porn every time
or do you just work off a memory show oh
[ __ ] I take it back to the eighth grade
finger banging this chick that's on
Facebook I saw the other day he's to
suck at Teddy's and anything I take it
back but Francine [ __ ] you know what's
weird about that
is that you're jerking off to a 15 year
old not really yeah your memory of her
was from back when she was 15 16 years
old I said you weren't this was 15 going
on 23 was a she was a very daughter I
think she's your grandfather didn't
because you were underage I looked her
up on Facebook and she looked really
good yeah then I was looking at one of
the papers no Mike Jesus Christ she grew
up to be a piece ass yeah I knew it I
knew her and her sister with this piece
of the house
well creeped me out about this piranhas
the eighth grade was my mother died I
went to a half a million what we're
gonna village for the where every will
the okay what time's your sister got
home by fire tearing it with time Jim
father yellow pots expertise your mother
yellow I was dead dog the dick died I
got a quickie anxiety spell I told her I
had a week I called her always later
broke up with you can't handle the
darkness it was cyclinder what would
what what what kind of child do for your
mother to die hmm
and [ __ ] him two years later my mother
died and I kept thinking about that girl
so from the time that I forgot her name
for years but if you know anything I
read about me
she was letter alone right I saw her
name was Maureen see I forget the
[ __ ] thing then I forget the last
name that sometimes it comes to me I'll
write it up mmm I got already down might
think that her like uh well I found her
on Facebook
I like Jesus Christ she still have big
titties she had two phenomenal titties
for an Irish chick she had that
strawberry head mmm
so she had freckles on her titties you
should drive me crazy I suck it till
he's right behind the church Saint
Michael's over there I figure in a would
[ __ ] be cold that's actually that muff
so big oh boy she's gonna knuckle jelly
she really was beautiful you think about
all that [ __ ] you know what I was
telling Lee one may even stop in her
life you looking this to 18 year olds of
books worth laying them down holdin
hands she's bad she's 18 or 22
he's 18 or the 19 he's a dumb [ __ ] but
they're going home because the MA
coming home till 5:00 and then basically
go home but jay-z Alvin [ __ ] like
savages and you think about how that's
never ever gonna happen yeah yeah yeah
like that's never gonna happen if you
get that young love when you walk home
with a girl you know you're gonna sling
dick but it's gotta take you 25 minutes
you know make that word can't uh connect
it then rub a [ __ ] and she'll put her
hands away from me then you go for the
tit your [ __ ] planes flying a bit and
then she finally gives you that Chile
and you rip his shirt off and that's it
your finger back over to the [ __ ]
jeans finally a pants come off you lick
it she starts crying she can't do it
she's packing why would you do this to
me
my brother's gonna kill you yeah and
then you split finger there again like a
savage that she gives him to the [ __ ] of
debt you know you flip over the cassette
tape put on side two that lets them
[ __ ] crazy yeah yeah yeah it's
exactly what you do all that well they
put just tape over just to bring girls
to your house and to make out with the
[ __ ] dry them yeah
Oh such a pleasure at that age people I
never understood I'll never get over
[ __ ] tits for the first time how is
were you safe grade so what's that 13
it's 13 years old but put this girl
Claire she had big-ass titties Jewish
grow a red hair big tits fun girl great
laugh and she let me suck her titties
outside up at Rockefeller the
Rockefellers had an estate up in a park
of where I grew up in Tarrytown right
across from Tappan Zee Bridge and we'd
go up there on the weekends we drink an
eight-pack of Michelob sit in the woods
and then try to suck tits and Claire
Claire let me suck her tits 13 yeah
that's just yet today no once get dick
would get home coming your pants yeah
only your face would get already [ __ ]
for 20 minutes and sucking go take a
second to a chance to fail
yeah he or she was maybe a [ __ ] hey you
can rub it tug it try to finger you when
she had that belt on tight yeah you had
to have your fingers broken to frickin
stick your fingers in that [ __ ]
snatch oh my god I miss that I'm
thinking about thinking like now if you
touched it's you enjoy it but you also
aware that you're doing it for her
pleasure as well you're trying to do it
in a nice way that will turn her on
back then it was only because you were
sucking on a tip like you never thought
about how it felt for her you were just
like I get to put a nipple in my mouth
and you'd suck out it like a baby hard
like a baby
youyou thought milk was actually gonna
come yeah it would you would go back to
being whatever the [ __ ] age you are it
really is like to be where you think
about even later on as I got older
casual sex people you think about now
you don't have that but yeah like what
are they thinking right you know they
probably have three kids though what are
they thinking but they think back about
that yeah always all that their minds
forgotten like most people mm-hmm you
know I don't remember all that [ __ ]
sometimes I said you were really only
let's go and I'll sit here with Liam
tell him Road stories to the so vile and
so disgusting that that alone is a
lesson don't con me on the road
I think throwing anything on the road
really teaches you a different side of
life it teaches you your manly but it
also teaches your people capable of
don't and you're away from home my gear
on the outside of you're like Rambo in
the first movie yeah are you feeling
though you happen to be home
yeah I'm happy to see my goddamn kids
you know my we just bought a new car so
tomorrow so my son just had his birthday
seventeenth birthday so we gave him the
car give my wife's car so he's he's
loving life seventeen he's got a
girlfriend he's got his own [ __ ] high
his Toyota Highlander not too sexy scar
but it's got some space got that third
row for his buddies he's gonna be to
choose be tooling around the west side a
light and there's one one girl that's it
he's got his girlfriend he's got someone
to take him for a few tickets hotel
Guinness we got a spot he's wearing life
he's a girl to put you with your yoga
girl when you when you find the spot my
main thing about it you start thinking
he's nobody else let me talk to you
about something over that time I found
you listen oh my god sama by my bar
you'd call for one night I can't do it
come on come on come on
why do you need my car because I need it
come on why I need well why you put me
through this one night I do whatever the
[ __ ] you want to never right yeah and
they'll torment you for gonna think it's
out listen this girl you want to [ __ ] in
my car that [ __ ] yeah I want to suck at
this get the [ __ ] out get the [ __ ] will
something to your house you stupid [ __ ]
you know don't like that it was
hysterical you inside the bar will call
for 300 yeah the first time I fooled
around and it wasn't outside or in
something with the wheels on it I mean
Jesus
especially you live in Jersey he must
have been [ __ ] around a lot of cars no
outside yeah outside tonight my mother
died I sucked these tits don't want her
biggest tip that you ever saw in your
life she was like I was a sophomore she
was a senior and I was on the hit of
acid that was just something like Ted
think it was the she had big a orders
that was the first time I saw that
areola she had those big semi artists
you know big Saudis yes right
she had slate teens 70 tits from Playboy
the big aorta
[ __ ] swamp what's it called how we
always do circle right
okay this circle not the nipple the
night your mother died you were on acid
sucking at girls tits earlier two hours
three three four hours before you knew
oh yeah before remember that game I took
off yeah I have a girl that knew the
neighborhood said follow me I don't more
people in them so we walked for a little
while the cops disappeared and then we
cut prom never forget that Street so
that still the same way we cut through
that and we got to a house and she goes
she goes we could hide in the back and I
knew a couple people that bill were
already they didn't Banga but stuff
happens I didn't know what happened
so I went up there very innocently I was
tripping on acid and next you know we
kept sitting closer to each other and
they smell was swamp and spirit I had to
sit out this [ __ ] mosquito net in all
those mosquito homes people and in
Jersey you go out there and sit in the
mosquitos or bother down like a little
gazebo it's like you gazebo something
back there with the pool furniture
Harold man - everything's back there put
away we got a tiptoe back there just
know two days earlier and I'm back this
sucking those tits like a [ __ ] like
was Ethiopian kids with a sable they
stop but if you see machine usually show
up with its if it's to bend this they
show pictures of woman machine you put
your lips on there looking for ladies
picture in your photo you think I like
Jesus what the [ __ ] you do yeah I'm
gonna bill for days somebody gives you
that breast milk what would you say
nothing you suck in that it to the
wrinkles come out
we're gonna hand underneath a little
[ __ ] you pick a deal with you say I got
a couple dates I'll be in Tampa Thursday
night we ain't [ __ ] around
listen if you live in the Tampa Sarasota
Clearwater area when I [ __ ] around
this weekend over there right bring your
guns bring it all we're taking damp got
improv calm go to tap and click on uncle
Joey that's gonna [ __ ] save your
weekend I'm ready to go I'm taking a
four-hour flight
I'm ready spitting somebody's [ __ ]
face I'm saying yeah I'm better than
going in the following week I know
Lexington Kentucky on Broadway nice
that's a good [ __ ] Club last time some
guys said [ __ ] you fat [ __ ]
we're Christians and he walked there hmm
holy Lexington Kentucky he'll be back
what's your plants you want to write
another show right here oh [ __ ] I got a
I want to get excited about you know
doing another one I was special I got I
got the our together and I put it on
tape over the next couple weeks and then
we're gonna go out and see where we can
sell it but I feel like it's been it's
been two and a half years of working on
this act I'm ready to [ __ ] put it up
and put it behind me cuz it's solid it's
all transition it's all chunks it's
ready and I'm not gonna be doing it in
six months you know and then make a
t-shirt that's it honey
I mean I've you sell t-shirts right no I
sell em all I know that's I'm saying you
guys so t-shirts on one yeah I don't
have any good coca-cola breakfast room
no I mean online I want to I got to make
a t-shirt I'll make a t-shirt you have a
[ __ ] great fits you know that
grapefruit Simmons yeah [ __ ] Irishman
yeah aka before the movie comes out
stake your claim
smack these homes
the session of Margaret Forsyth say
write all that on one t-shirt yeah we're
gonna force it let's go fishing I am
from Paraguay mixi together but Harvey
was he's gonna be out to collect we're
[ __ ] jaw Vaseline Wow the big I have
you listing boat so they asked passing
you don't override your boy with a
missing if I don't be like what's going
on English I have this big project
coming up your bigs are gonna produce it
or the [ __ ] just look in the answer if
you take some pictures Greg this job
pays six of the gzip foot residuals just
bridges I my office send over the
contract the travel you know things
happen you're falling yet that's the
next lesson they come about Harvey
Weinstein that's what they gotta go with
a rain he's already starting to burn
this [ __ ] yeah if he [ __ ] is that
much of a pervert he's got pictures
hell yeah he's got cameras lined up that
dudes been taking pictures he's got a
pig figure what a pelt rose [ __ ] I know
he does a little skinny bony [ __ ]
thing yeah yeah now they all want to
speak up against some new [ __ ]
the other one I enjoy your Joey said he
used the other one the [ __ ] lentil truck
yeah what a Paltrow what are you gonna
do four years you're headed back now
you're gonna tell us and then the other
one won the Academy Award went up there
thank them yeah so you got no
credibility [ __ ] yeah I know let's say
Harvey wants things to suck a little
Asian dicks yeah over I drink with
summonses ass
it hit don't even know where he's got a
knife you don't know where he's going
all he sees is [ __ ] lights either
said what's out there you look confused
I'm fine alright just checking with you
what do you want tonight Lee huh
take any mushrooms or cut to a little
bit of everything
feeling good you know feel fine the boss
real ah I don't know I feel a little bit
no not really bad did you taste anything
by the Texas town career but now there's
nowhere tense exhale you like a little
joy tell the people on the microphone
window what take scaling me no I'm dead
this Bay yeah you told me you don't want
you want marshal reorder to taste like
[ __ ] I went out of my way to get them
direct to you from the [ __ ] phone
you have appreciated think that's a type
of [ __ ] I am you know I'm saying
you your wish is my command
farm to table that's it wait away to
[ __ ] Pittsburgh you know I'm saying I
flew him in there you have it direct
from the phone you want the restaurant
great take a look at me will you give a
[ __ ]
take them home have a party with your
wife don't sit Oh goods of [ __ ] put in
the middle of those I'm gonna be is
either or donut I bring Harvey Weinstein
oh yeah lasagna I'll put on the Harvey
Weinstein mess nobody knows then you
won't like a trick Cosby though it goes
button right now is the time to attack
what would Harvey Weinstein mask yeah do
it tonight I'd be out there stalking
[ __ ] will Sudan is that Halloween
costume you think people are gonna wear
that for Halloween
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah please but
tonight I would go out with a Harvey
Weinstein face they wear a suit on the
Santa Monica's stabbed a [ __ ] I
want my career back and just family take
the best of all points books of living a
father fight scene whatever is [ __ ]
Vegas go Jeff for a few weeks issues we
saw you go you did those accounts we
counseling you worthy
well I'm a dinosaur I gotta catch up
with these modern ways that's what he
said well I grew up in the sixties and
seventies you know ya know we talk of
the sixties and seventies listen I grew
up in the sixties and seventies I say
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] a couple years ago
some girl I shook her hand she worked
for the club and I shook her hand I had
met him before I think you still work
here I remember yes because I remember
you too
you grabbed my [ __ ] wonder they only
throw him
I know you got me confused but I don't
even come here I come here twice EDF
flappers pen trust me I just wouldn't
reach out and grab your [ __ ] I was the
old coke you're taking your chances of
your variance and we're having a ball
with me you come in here with a
miniskirt that's a wall Ted second walk
in the night I go to bars of just
salivating over those waitresses
salesmen like [ __ ] the Henry L know
what's he like yeah I had the Volkswagen
he was killing [ __ ] everywhere
oh yeah over Florida right um chart not
Dahmer that cocaine makes you you know
evil yeah so when you're in a bar and
the girl gives you a look what's a
regular look to you is a look to me that
means I'm gonna suck your dick like we
really believe the strip club thing when
you're on coke she stacked up a leader
at death at two o'clock
we'll wait for her she loves me Dawg she
gonna leave a husband because your
friends like oh yeah you know what bro I
believe you right hand you you meet your
[ __ ] girlfriend no it's a sick [ __ ]
thing we get that delusion hmm yeah we
will be doing this weekend this weekend
no plans no dog show no blue a blue
contest none that I'm aware of yet no I
don't think how many plans no plans well
I haven't everybody I'm firing that's it
good for you you were talking to talk
about therapy tonight you just went back
good for you we had discussion about
that a while back improperly what do you
look under the table for it's a big day
man big day first first day back in
therapy in years walked in got my
therapist Jesus uh really old she's an
old lady and she's Native American and
she just gets me you know she's great I
live with her
did I used to go for I I went for a few
years and then I stopped for I think she
said it's been six years since I've seen
her and and then she told me that I
should be taking what's that stuff the
the pot that doesn't have any CBB you
see she told me to start taking CBDs
every day she goes but don't tell
anybody I told
I said alright so I went home I took
CBDs I had a bunch that Pete Holmes gave
me a whole he sponsors it I think the
same stuff that Rogan does it's good
[ __ ] good [ __ ] yeah it takes care
sometimes I forget I think an aspirin or
something hmm something hurts like Oh
hissing I got that CB deal yeah cabinet
yeah and the pain you forget about it
but the next morning it's how you feel
yeah that's what I like about the CBD
phone mm-hmm that's I don't know
anything about that people always hit me
up but I don't know really much about it
hmm
I know how it works for a fat [ __ ] who
tries to work out I don't know how works
for you know other things other ailments
I feel a little high from it which
you're not supposed to they say that
there's no properties that should make
you high but and I said that to her and
she goes well it's probably because the
stress you're normally feeling is gone
when you take the CBDs and so you
actually feel high relative to how you
normally feel I said all right I'll take
that yeah that'll work completely yeah
so I got about four giant bottles of
that lined up we doing that every day
for a while and you know visualizing she
said we're gonna do a lot of visualizing
the way you know sports you know sports
psychologists they tell you to see
yourself getting up to the plate
watching the ball swinging at the ball
hitting the ball whatever she's the same
thing with life you can picture how
situations are gonna play out and you
just you you run it through your head
enough times it starts that starts to
happen that way because you you allow it
to happen that way it's a good train of
thought Natalie yes no no that's always
you always see yourself like that you're
gonna die you look at a picture yourself
you used to be in you normally get that
fat think so and she says it's
repetition the more you think it the
more you create new pathways in your
brain and it happens you know just being
good Greg Fitzsimmons that's why I love
you that that thanks man
love you Taylor chords if you once ago
you told me you are the tire I was happy
for you that's a great show for you yeah
you know the life you know Pete Holmes
you know right easy to write he's a
stand-up comic on the way up Jesus
Christ right we all have something put
on that it's over that's lights out
that's a great show yeah I'm proud of
you
thanks man you're [ __ ] everything
about with you would be looking good
baby he does he dropped some serious
first thing I noticed he came down those
stairs and said Jesus not only looks
lighter but he looks brighter no no he's
a different [ __ ] man he's taking
vitamins II don't know right he's doing
the kettlebells eat daughter yeah I do
in the kettlebells and I did for a while
like six months last year did it three
days a week
I gotta [ __ ] my son try but nobody came
a year ago so I'm doing a little I'm
doing better than when I was last year
yeah you sure yes [ __ ]
you taking long walks no but I wanted
the jet I didn't hour on the elliptical
wow that's amazing an hour Jesus Christ
that's a lame what went back when I was
a chiropractor yesterday I'm sitting
there right and let the coffee shop when
I got home I know what that [ __ ] like
I know but I saw my back you know [ __ ]
that I put my running sneakers on and I
[ __ ] put my iPod on and I went for a
walk of death mm-hmm I want to run that
part three times you know what I wasn't
huffing and puffing when I got old my
shirt was dress yeah it feels nice to go
for a walk myself I am gonna just other
pain to us as I wasn't old might use
that spray yeah I was in [ __ ] pain
everything hurts
these shin bones the lower backs I went
home I took a shower I was right there
in the bathroom I hit six one two my
tongue I feel a little better and I buy
her a [ __ ] little kiss just add it to
the body count at this point you follow
listen like I told you in the beginning
of the show and I'm not fooling around
which lips believes that being a right
sharing driver should be fun if you're
having a good time
so you're passing this and that's what
everybody says about lifts everybody
says lyft drivers are the best drivers
out there
now lift knows that they're drivers or
keep them moving so they do everything
they can to make
sure that drivers are happy on every
trip it's a simple form of the happy
drivers means happy passengers maybe
that's why 9 out of 10 lift rides got a
perfect vibrating you can earn hundreds
of dollars a week plus tips you want to
earn more money drive more it's never
been easier to give yourself a raise
lift was the first right shape platform
with tipping built right into the yet
because getting tip shouldn't depend on
your passenger having a crumpled build
in this pocket they didn't blow out of
two years ago you keep 100% of the tips
and they add up fast drivers have been
paying over two hundred million dollars
since the feature was introduced an
express play lets you get paid almost
instantly instead of waiting for weeks
for a check like some motive on lift has
even taken the guesswork out of pickups
the new amp device uses color coding to
help passengers find their drivers
listen knocked it off join the
ride-sharing company that believes in
treating its people better go to lift
calm / Joey Jo ey today right now stop
and get up do something you can get a
five and halle-loo driver bonus that's
lift calm / Joey lift calm / Joey go
there right now
limited time only terms apply we think
it'd be a little obvious
that was a good paddle [ __ ] around these
people are taking a left on tonight I
know Oh relax
always always why play games in the sand
Lisa at the truth well you want on your
little blue aprons diet you look good
you lost weight you were doing it you
were sticking to it then Paula got the
job you got busy but how good was blue
apron it's great and they're making it
even better they've made it so you don't
take it all through recipes now they
have a ton more recipes to look at and
the Foods always fresh and even better
they have amazing customer service my
dad was just saying the other day they
if you ever have an issue what you
rarely do you call them out that you
email them
you call them and they're amazing and
nice to deal with so that Mia they're
mean quick quick they don't play games
which is what you want old-school style
what is blue apron off eeeh
it's affordable for less than $10 per
person per meal boy brings only the
seasonal recipes along with proportion
ingredients to make your delicious
home-cooked meals it's flexible you
customize your recipes each week based
on your preference
blue eight but there's several delivery
options so you can choose what fits your
needs and there's no weekly commitment
so you only get deliveries when you one
each meal comes in a step-by-step
easy-to-follow recipe card and their
free portion ingredients can be prepared
and forty minutes or less sorry about
that
did you hear me before it's easy also
each meal comes with a step-by-step
easy-to-follow recipe card and
proportional ingredients and can be
prepared and forty minutes or less the
guarantee is beautiful blue aprons
freshness guarantee promises that every
ingredient your delivery arrives ready
to cook or they'll make it right in the
errantly
it's tremendous customer service you're
in good hands so do me a favor
check out this week's menu and get 30%
off your first meal for free in this
damning free weather it's seafood the
beef the chicken two pork you're gonna
love it right now I'm gonna check out
this week's menu get 30% off your first
meal with free shipping to boot by going
to blueprint calm slash Joey listen
you're gonna love it getting the Liberty
house you're gonna love how good it
feels and how good it tastes and you
love how to how good you are creating
incredible home-cooked meals with blue
apron so listen don't wait what are you
waiting for
that's blue apron calm slash Joey again
$30 off your first meal with free
shipping blue apron calm slash Joey a
better way to cook all right one more
time for my brother there
the Irishman one more time for the
[ __ ] [ __ ] my main man I love
you [ __ ] have a great week
I'll see you guys in Tampa don't forget
about me [ __ ] bring the reefer
and I'll see you next week and Lexington
Kentucky on on Broadway all right so
have a great weekend stay black see you
Monday [ __ ] love you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]